hello everyone some of you may have
heard the big news some of you may have
not but Vladimir Kramnik announced that
he's retiring from professional chess he
said that he made the decision a few
months back but now Tata Steel has
officially been his last well
professional tournament he will of
course stay in the chess world he will
use his great influence and knowledge to
you know pass the knowledge on he will
I'm sure he will coach kids be part of
organizations that promote chess and do
what he can to you know be included in
every possible way in in chess other
than playing professionally such as for
example like Garry Kasparov he is still
extremely active in promoting chess but
like I said as for playing he will no
longer be playing so a lot of it said we
should show a nice game as you know in
honor of big Vlad so it so it wasn't an
easy decision which game to show it had
to be against someone very strong
against someone in his prime so I
thought which better game then a game
against none other than world champion
Garry Kasparov this is a game from 1996
it was played in dos hermanas in Spain
and it was a tournament that featured 10
of the strongest players in the world
we're going to talk about the results of
the tournament after I showed the game
but it's a really a beautiful game
really an explosive game
it's like Kasparov is playing against
Kasparov but it's people do say that
prior to chronics match with Kasparov or
the World Chess Championship chronic
style was a bit different in order to
overcome such challenge and to defeat
Garry Kasparov chroming had to become
what he what he is today the positional
machine but in those days you know
anything could happen so let's see what
happened in one such game as this one
the four by Kasparov we have d 5 C 4 and
we have C 6 the game was played in 1960
and 1996 and don't know if I mentioned
that Knights the C 3 we have Knight to
f6 Knight to f3 and d6 so the semi Slav
defense is on
bored III but Kasparov Knight B to d7
we have Bishop to d3 and only now that
the Bishop has been developed thus
Cromley capture and on C for forcing
Bishop to waste a few Tempe we have the
ship captures on c4 b5 mushroom goes
back this was all the stat all standard
theory at the time and it still is today
Bishop to b7 developing light square
bishop and as long as black can at some
point play C 5 as the knight and Bishop
are very nicely controlling c5 the
bishop the light square bishop on b7
will come alive this broken coming to
the game via c8 or perhaps if the Queen
moves to d8 so all is well for black at
the moment because power of castles and
we have a 6 here strengthening the b5
pawn and so c6 is the a c5 is the plan
we have E 4 by Kasparov and now II five
is a pretty big positional threat for
example if you play a slow move like
rook c8 d 5 is definitely coming and
after 95 and I capture C captures and
then after let's say for you attack the
the b5 pawn be four and then a five and
it's really hard for black to play this
game you really take away a lot of
squares from this Knight can't really go
anywhere after but should be seven
developing you you will castle and play
the game but white will just be much
better the bishop pair already very
nicely eyeing that King side what white
will just have a much better game but
that was also all very known at the time
so after this efore c5 micronic this is
this was still part of theory black
cannot waste time d5 by Kasparov we have
c4 forcing the bishop back Bishop to see
to and now Queen to c7 developing the
Queen and also leaving the option of
Castle King side and but also both Queen
side and here we have night to d4 and
what's interesting about this night to
d4 move Kasparov played is that well a
lot of years after 15 years after
Kasparov played at Magnus Carlsen also
played it in the 2011 bill chess
festival against the Alexis Europe and
after sure went a five-person win Knight
f5 and Carson was able to win a very
nice game but
this 15 years before that game Carlson
versus share of a Kramnik win tonight
the c5 and we have a completely
different game well obviously as it was
played 15 years before that game but I'm
sure about cousin and sheriff knew about
this famous game between Casper man
Kramnik in 1996 so if I was supposed to
serve as a most likely as a surprise to
Carlson but okay getting back to this
game before Casper has power now forces
things with a psychiatrist on b3 Ambus
on a captures and now before kicking
this night back and this will result in
this eforp on well being defenseless by
this by doing this as part of basically
kramnik basically wins upon we have
knife to a4 and now comes night seek
after sunny for so Kasparov decided to
sacrifice this efore pawn we have Bishop
captures Knight captures and now D
captures on e6 so because pyro grabs
upon back and it's very interesting Ken
Kramnik take back the pawn if you play F
captures on e6 then you get Knight
captures and then all hell breaks loose
your queen is under attack your better
pass under attack you have to react to
this Queen in five
now comes Knight captures on f8 rook
captures and here comes Bishop to b2 now
the knight and the rim comes very handy
as it protects the bishop on b2 the
queen is under attack Queen has to move
and are threatening all sorts of ideas
if this Knight moves
so h4 this is quite a forced line and Oh
both gasp are on chronic Shirley
calculated it out Queen captures and now
f3 everything is now defended that the
knight has to move on Knight c3
Bishop captures B captures and now
Knight the c5 and here white will just
be much better the the bishop is under
attack Queen d7 is the threat of
checkmate you have to react to this you
have to go back up c6 control d7 and get
the bishop out of danger now but then
Queen b6 and it's very unlikely that
black will be able to survive all this
pressure
the roofs cannot come into the into the
game and it's just not black will not be
able to defend all
threats so after this D captures only
six Kramnik does not capture back rather
he plays Bishop to d6 prefers D H to
pawn cuz para grabs the f7 pawn as well
we have a captures on f7 with Czech
Queen captures and here again it's a
very delicate position chronics King is
still in the center of the board but
kramnik pieces are also all eyeing as
part of sking so what do you play here
if you play something like Bishop to e3
then black can castle now there's a lot
of pressure against the f2 pawn after f3
trying to kick the knight back you get a
nice the c3 Knight captures B captures
and here after Queen to b3 black can go
Queen to h5 at some point this Queen to
h5 will always come and the black polo
create threats against the h2 pawn and
now let's say if a foreign Queen d5
again you pressure the g2 pawn and
however a white continues playing this
game black will always be better black
will always be able to find one more
resource to be able to continue the
attack let's say rook f3 rook 8 the e8
is coming and you can see that the
blacks position is just much more active
after white makes a move you can go
Bishop captures an eye for this rook
cannot move due to the threats of
checkmate on g2 so after Bishop captures
rook captures now your knight is
threatened as well after you move the
knight rookie to is coming now rubgy 4
will be an idea and everything will pile
up against this g2 pawn seems like it
would be too much pressure for white so
Kasparov plays the absolute best move he
plays f3 immediately he forces Kramnik
to decide what to do here but one thing
this f3 pawn does it prevents the Queen
from keeping an eye on the h5 squares so
instead of reacting to this Kramnik
simply goes Queen to h5 and it is the
the precise idea now if it's power of
captures the knight Queen captures on h2
is deadly King f2 you can castle with
check King has to move and now you go
Queen captures an G to the the King will
simply not be able to survive on e3
white it doesn't have any good moves
here so after a Queen to h5 will
three now keeping an eye on that and now
Kramnik again has to make a decision
chromic already decided he will part
with his night but will he do it in a
way that he will allow Kasparov the
capture it or would would he sacrifice
ng3 it there is the possibility of night
captures and g3 if H captures and only
then castles it's still a lot of
pressure for Kasparov the handle but I
have to look to 82 it seems a wide to
defense let's say but what captures here
but now Roop can come to g2 and it seems
the white successfully defended against
everything and kramnik does not want to
allow that after g3 kramnik decides to
Castle and allow cost part of the
capture on e4 if he wishes so Kasparov
does capture it is the best move with F
captures on e4 and now Queen to h3 and
this is now a very important moment in
the game Kasparov has to decide how to
continue in this game if he can somehow
survive this attack he is up a piece for
now his extra piece is this Knight and
a4 which isn't doing all that much but
if he can defend get this Knight into
the game then he will have an excellent
game here Kasparov played Knight to f3
and he allowed Kramnik a bit too much
with which Queen to e2 he would prevent
the special characters on g3 idea one
such line would be Bishop captures and
g3 and now white ignores black and goes
night at five and here white what
everything just works out for white now
you have to move the bishop after Bishop
to e5 you can go Bishop b2 again you can
use this weird 1984 as a protector of
the bishop on b2 after Bishop captures
and now Knight captures the knight also
can come back into the game
rook a d8 now Queen the Seaforth checked
and after Queen King moves Knight goes
back to g3 and the knight now very
nicely defends de-spawn everything is
connected the rooks are connected and
white is able to play this game on
butkis para went for a different line he
went the knight to f3 and now from next
idea works out he plays virtual
characters on g3 and now again if you
play H chapters on g3 its it's just game
over for Kasparov Queen captures after
King
now comes the bushel captures on e4
there's a triple attack against the
knight on f3 and whatever you do let's
say you want to introduce another
defender into the game then simply rook
captures and it's all over
rook captures Bishop characters you have
to give up the Queen captures captures
and after King moves now you simply
bring the other rook into the game you
can go rookie to check it's all over for
white
so after this Bishop captures and g3 cuz
para went Knights the c5 he wants to
eliminate the bishop on b7 which is a
pretty terrifying piece but now by doing
this he also says that I'm not worried
about rook captures on f3 rook captures
on f3 removed the defender of the h2
pawn
so if rook captures on f3 the Queen is
then allowed to capture back so Romney
goes for this we have group captures and
now again Kasparov has to make a
decision either he will capture or he
will go rook to Luke to a2 which defends
the h2 point once again in the game
Kasparov captured which was not the best
the best course of action but at least
it's hoping for something if you go
Roque to nan Kramnik can simply trade it
down into into a better endgame for
example Queen captures you force a trade
of Queens Queen captures rook captures
team captures and now rook the c8 a very
powerful move if now captures then you
can capture on c5 and after Bishop to e3
now you have Bishop to f4 you get your
Bishop arrow out of the way and also
after Bishop captures you will capture
here and you will have this endgame an
opposite called Bishop end game where
Kramnik would be up upon but but with
also a better position so it's one way
to do it but Kasparov did not want to go
into this with the white piece it would
seem so after loop to f3 we have root
characters on f3 you have to capture
with the rook so as after the Queen
captures you make room for the King on
f1 Queen captures on h2 with check King
to f1 and now comes the move that
perhaps as part of mist otherwise he
would have most likely gone into that
opposite color Bishop endgame where he
is down upon defending a worse position
but you know feel free to pause the
video here and try to find how to
continue this attack
would black in the most precise fashion
I'll give you a couple of seconds
you know just so you get into the mood
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
the MOOC as part of most likely missed
is Bishop to c6 preparing Bishop to b5
and this check will be deadly and
there's not all that much you can do if
you decide to play something like
looking for okay five after Bishop to b5
to give up the exchange simply Bishop
the c7 attacking the rook and now after
her White's try some sorcery with Bishop
12 for with ideas of forcing black to
capture back then Queen 8:1 check kinky
- now you can capture Queen captures
King captures and only now will you
eliminate this rope here so this would
be excellent for black so here Kasparov
tried Bishop to g5 as far as idea is
that he wants to meet Bishop to b5
checked with Knight to d3 and he doesn't
want to allow this rook to come to da so
Bishop from g5 very nicely defends the
d8 square but okay Bishop to b5 check
crowning display this we have nice to d3
but now rook to e8 and it seems Kasparov
doesn't have all that much to do here
cuz Peres went rook 282 hoping for Queen
captures rook so the rook and the lease
at least eliminate one of the attackers
but here chronic just ignored him
kramnik well here comes the only bad
part of this game in my opinion here
Kramnik has a forced checkmate in four
moves but the problem is a chronic found
a different win so he stopped looking
for a faster one but you are you know
comfortable in your own home I presume
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the force to checkmate him
for a one-minute missed here I'll give
you a couple of seconds as usual for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
you know seeker of checkmates but for
the duke who just won't enjoy the show
Bishop captures on d3 with check it's
not very often that when you have to
find the correct idea it will start with
check but this is one such occasion
now you are in check you have to capture
we have rook captures on d3 and the now
comes Queen to h1 check it's similar to
the idea
chronic had in the game but through a
different move order but now after king
e2 you have Queen to G to check King to
e3 and now the Queen very nicely
controls the e4 pawn here rook captures
on e4 will be checkmate chronics idea
was a different a chronic first started
with Queen to h1 check we have King to
e2 and now if you go Queen to g2 check
the Queen will no longer control the e4
square because the rook is on f3 you did
not capture on d3 first
so now after King to be to first look
after Sonny form was played by chronic
we have king to d2 and only now Queen to
g2 with check King c1 and now chronic
wins the rockin a 2 we have Queen
captures I need to look after son g3 and
now Queen 2 a1 check clink the c2 and
now Queen the c3 check now we have King
Tubby 1 and here Cromley just played
rook to d4 attacking the pin piece and
it was in this position that garry
kasparov resigned the game why did he
resign well your knight is attacked
three times there's no way to further
defend it if you try something like King
gate to get out of any checks and hope
to continue the game it will not work
simply Bishop captures and after let's
say you try Quincy one to trade Queen's
rook d5 and you will force White's to
trade and after Queen captures you will
play phone captures and now you have a
very dangerous passed pawn here whatever
white plays let's say before you go C to
and then now let's say Bishop h6 you
pressure the pawn here but to g6 and now
I have to rub the G to black will simply
enjoy this it's still an opposite called
bishop in game but kramnik would be up
three points and with the passport and
c2 it will not be possible for for
crossbar of the defendant and also this
point will be very weak as this the king
will have to be included in the defense
well in stopping the past C pawn on the
other hand after rook to d4 you could
try something like Knights to c1 or for
a queen trade you capture my queen or
capture yours but it doesn't work if
rook captures rook captures on c3 now
captures king see - yes you will
eliminate the past pawn but after Luke -
f1 King captures now you're down the
exchange and also kramnik is up two
points so again a completely winning
position for Kramnik yeah after rook to
d4 casparo resigned the game and like I
said the only bad part about this game
is that Kramnik didn't go for the force
making 4 and he could have finished the
game much sooner but he found a
different win so it's just the same
something that will happen very often
when you find a when you no longer care
if there's a faster win you know I'm
beating world champion garry kasparov
here I don't care how I beat him and I
also did prepare the final standings
after the 1996 dos hermanas tournament
there we have it as you can see Kramnik
won the tournament alongside Apollo with
six out of nine then with final five and
a half you have Anand and Kasparov tied
which means that if Kasparov didn't lose
this game against kramnik meaning that
either if he drew the game then Kasparov
would be tied with the Polo for first
place but if Kasparov won again
scrambling here with the white pieces
then Kasper would be the sole leader of
this tournament so definitely an
important game for both chronic and the
tournament the final tournament
standings then you have LS Cordoba the
the Spanish favorite player gata Kamsky
Boris Gelfand the vastly venture with
three and a half out of nine not the
greatest tournament for for a good
Sharky alexei shiro with three and a
three other nine and the you dispo gar
also with three other nine so an
excellent victory for Kramnik and also
an excellent tournament victory for
avoiding Kramnik so as you can see today
you will know chromic mostly as the you
know extremely precise positional player
that you know punishes every slight
imprecision like a machine but in the
old days before he became world champion
he would often have a game like this
against none other than world chess
champion Garry Kasparov and also I
prepared something very exciting well I
hope it will be something very exciting
I prepared for you a scores between
between Vladimir Kramnik
and some of the world champions
throughout his life so here we have one
such
score between Vladimir Kramnik and
Anatoly Karpov
as you can see kramnik and Karpov in
classical games so kramnik won two games
Carper won two games and ten draws so
out of the 14 games they are tied in
classical chess
then we have Kramnik score against Garry
Kasparov as you can see in classical
games
Vladimir Kramnik beat Gary Kasparov five
to four with 40 draws so in classical
chess Kramnik has a positive score
against Garry Kasparov just something to
show you how strong kramnik really was
then we have kramnik score again his
lifetime score against which wonít and
Anand
as you can see what Amir kramnik tied
Vishwanathan Anand 11 to 11 with 71
draws so many games between these two
rivals and in the end it's a tie again
his well lifetime score against another
world champion then we well it wouldn't
be much of a show showing if we didn't
show his lifetime score against the none
other than the reigning world champion
Magnus Carlsen here it is
chronic score against Magnus Carlsen
Carlsen beat Vladimir Kramnik six to
five with 16 draws so against a player
that is considered to be one well he is
considered to be the strongest player in
history Kramnik only losses by a
one-point margin so six to five with 16
draws and it wouldn't also be much of a
showing if we didn't show kramnik score
against none other than the great Chucky
not a world champion but definitely a
strong player especially in those days
when he was just beating everyone
everyone knows that Chucky can lose
against the 2100 player but on a good
day you know even even alpha0 would
think twice before challenging Chucky
as you can see a kramnik against Chucky
vitomir Kramnik beat vasily von Schuch
11 to 6 with 31 ross so the only one out
of these five extremely powerful players
that has a positive score against
Vladimir Kramnik is Magnus Carlsen and
only by a one-point margin so that's how
that's how good Latimer Kramnik is and
like I said although he retired from
professional chess
he retired from playing he will of
course I believe he will be included in
the chess world for the rest of his life
but you know we'll just have to wait and
see so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and it's a bit too early to
start a chronic saga maybe in a few
years but we'll definitely get to that I
would also like to thank Ken it said
that now I feel the reverse a Gregory
liar Mick Vaughn the drift and the
buoyance of each of each for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with another
interesting game as usual I hope thank
you all and I will see you soon